What's your favorite movie memory?
What I mean is,
what's your fondest memory while watching a movie?
The question came to me this morning when I
was watching the first episode of Louis C.K.'s
Horace and Pete.
It's a TV show that he produced on his website
and it's great.
There's this interesting segment where an old
man enters their bar.
I'm gonna let the whole scene play out.
I really encourage you to get the first episode if you enjoy this.
My mother would send me here for a pale of beer for my dad.
Other man- Yeah, we used to sell beer pales out the back.
First man- Yeah, and I, I,... I came here to get my first beer.
And I met my wife here.
she was sitting *points* in, in that stool.
Yeah, and we were, we were married for- years and *sighs*
I- I was happy and, um, then I heard that she was sleeping with my best friend
and so I showed up here one night and- uh- she was sitting in that stool, again,
with my, best friend kissing her.
And, I just shot them both dead.
That was back in 1961.
I just got outta, got outta jail today.
*stifled laughter*
*Man cry-laughs*
NowYouSeeMe- Is that guy really there?
Other man- Hey, you want a beer?
Man- *croaks* yeah.
So here's my question-
Was that segment tragic or funny?
I think the first instinct is to find it morbid.
Certainly a man murdering his wife and spending his life in prison is tragic.
But the way it's presented is also comedic.
It's a rollercoaster of events.
I was choking on my morning bagel from laughter at how this story got absurdly worse and worse.
I'm a big believer that the funniest moments are the ones that are also the saddest.
I watched "Daddy's home" the other day and it's fine.
It had some good laughs, but with comedies like "Daddy's home" there's always something missing.
And that brings me to my point, the funniest movies are also the saddest movies.
It's the Tragicomedy.
Hear me out on this one-
I venture to say that the vast majority of comedy these days
contains characters who serve no other purpose but to make us laugh.
Stuff like "Bridesmaids" and "Spaceballs"